Linda mearns from the National Center of
this is unique this is a serious
electrical series on regional kind of
change that were holding through this
semester of reps p.m. Linda is directed
weather and climate impact assessment
science program her that just keep going
so she's also the head of regional
integrated science collected within the
Institute of mathematics and Applied
Sciences senior science and national
cemetery but he said in an author and
IPCC reports from to do the latest one I
love you thank you my god so so that's
all the whole nine first 11 thank you
anybody anybody i just i was ready
assessment abilities that's her interest
is in time variability on a regional
scale at today's talk will be on
credibility of this sort of thing model
predictions for the future thank you
live thanks for being so patient
certainly I hope everybody is planning
to stay in extra 15 minutes for my words
of wisdom anyway I'm very happy to be
here I've already had a great morning
and lunch chatting with people every
interaction has been enjoyable and
education and can one ask for more I
don't think so all right so I've done a
lot of work with regional models and
just regional climate change projections
also from global models and this issue
of the credibility of climate model
projections particularly on the regional
scale has gotten a lot of attention but
there are many many challenges so this
is going to be sort of a sort of medium
big view of this problem and by the way
I realize this is a mixed audience I
like mixed audiences but it's hard to
know what people know but I know that I
don't know what you know and so it's not
an unknown unknown which is good so if I
say anything or use an acronym or
whatever that you don't understand
please stop me because I'd much rather
that you understand okay so credibility
is costs related to uncertainty and this
is one of my favorite quotes from
Voltaire about that doubt is not a
pleasant condition but certainty is an
absurd one and I certainly think this is
true about regional climate change there
will always be uncertainty in it and the
other half of that is and that's okay
because in point of fact we all know how
to make decisions under uncertainty so
basically what a lot of what I'm going
to be talking about is how can we best
evaluate the quality of climate models
and establish their credibility
and I think on the next slide hopefully
I have something about all right so
partially this relates to what's the
purpose what are you going to use these
climate projections for and I've divided
the possible reasons for establishing
reliability or credibility to these
three sort of bins one is for
recommending what scenarios should be
used for impact assessments research in
impacts but more and more commonly now
there's more pressure for to produce
scenarios of future climate change for
actual decision making a water resource
manager for example in Denver and one of
the interesting points as well is the
standard of credibility different if
you're just doing impacts research
versus if you're actually spending money
for example to actually start developing
infrastructure in an adaptation plan but
in the implementation of a plan another
one of course that I'm very familiar
with is selecting which global models
should be used to drive regional climate
models and how many of you are here for
ray Eretz talk last week okay so you
guys are pretty familiar with the whole
idea of nesting a regional model inside
a GCM and by saying that anybody he
wasn't at that talk you've kind of got
the basics right there and then another
important task is for differential
weighting of different models to provide
better measures of uncertainty and this
has to do with the the model democracy
problem like is it does each model
global climate model get a vote in let's
say an ensemble of climate model
simulations so I'm going to be
discussing this in terms of multi-model
ensemble both global and regional
climate models and needles to say these
multi-model ensembles do not cover all
the possible uncertainty but it's a it's
a common way of looking at a certain
type of uncertainty so what do we mean
by this for a long time oh here's a
question how many of you were
live in 1989 maybe i should say the
other way who is not alive in 1989 one
two three okay so i asked this because
the next slide i'm going to show has to
do with 1989 and so for the longest time
it's kind of climate modelers analyst
would make statements that if the model
reproduce observations well whatever
that means which really means whatever
the reviewers of the article would
tolerate then we would have confidence
in future projection but my argument is
that just doing better in terms of
biases is really not adequate for any of
the purposes I indicated earlier okay so
here is our slide from 1989 joel smith
at all this was from the EPA report on
climate change in the US and this is
back when most of the model experiments
were done is just two times co two
experiments and so these just give the
comparisons oh yes this I should
probably use this but it works so here's
three different models that gives the
gfdl and what was then known as the osu
model and so for the lower 48 for the
four seasons you have changes in
temperature and changes in pre-civil
meters per day and of course one of the
things that was very disturbing to
people then was oh my god we have an
opposite direction of change and what do
we do about that and what does that mean
what's interesting 8999 2009 so 25 years
later at least we really still do not
know how to manage this problem to the
degree that it is a problem although
there have been some improvements the
other thing about the two times co2
experiments there was this strange rule
about this that if your biases were
smaller than the two times co to climate
change
then you were okay if it was larger than
you weren't okay and when you think
about that that's an incredibly
arbitrary metric for having confidence
in a result but that's actually and i
participated in articles in which we
made that claim okay so here we are now
with sort of newer simulations this is a
change in summer precip theater from the
SEMA three models seema three models
that the group of models that were used
in the last assessment report global
climate models and this is just a
snapshot of you know two very different
responses from the gfdl this is changing
seasonal average precip from the mid
century mid 21st century back to the end
of the 20th or the beginning of now the
end of the 20th yes we're in the 21st
right and so that's the result from gfdl
for summer precip and here's the results
from ccsm and note you know just very
large differences in some of these areas
and again what does that mean does it
mean we don't have confidence in either
of these models both of those models and
so forth so relationship to uncertainty
now this is has to do with the model
democracy so historically and generally
most of the recent IPCC reports although
i'm going to show you an example where
this isn't the case each climate model
is given equal weight in summarizing the
model results so each model how many of
you are familiar with the rcps the newer
scenarios of concentrations nodding okay
so
for the last report it was the s.res
emission scenarios this time around it's
the rcps in many ways from the point of
view of climate response it doesn't make
that much of a big difference except for
the aerosols in either case the point is
does each model provide the same level
of useful information about the future
or should some models be down waited
because they're really crummy in some
aspect or another and this has been you
know an ongoing battle and there's been
just a plethora of articles about how to
wait these models one of the problems is
we have a relatively large earth with
different regions so does it matter if
you do a good job on the South Asian
monsoon but a poor job on the south west
North American monsoon does that matter
in other words what are the
teleconnections should you be able to do
all Mon seen as well to be able to have
a wait if you're concerned with changes
in monsoon areas so as I said there's
been rapid developments and had
differentially wait climate model
simulations particularly in
probabilistic models of uncertainty of
regional climate change and I'll show
you some examples of that so the first
one actually that Filippo and I sleep Oh
Georgie and I did in 2002 2003 was what
we call the REA method not a very Rhea
it's not a very attractive afternoon but
there we are so this provided summary
measures of regional climate change
based on weighted average of the climate
model responses and the weights were
based on the model reliability weights
based on model reliability it does not
say the same thing hmm I don't
understand what I was saying there let's
skip that line there were two different
criteria one was of course the
performance of the AO GCM some kind of
evaluation and the other was modelled
convergence which ended up being a very
let's say an issue that people had a lot
of opinions on
that convergence well why should
convergence in and of itself indicate
greater reliability what was interesting
about that was that that's what when I
gave this presentation or other people
did filippo they would say well
convergence is not a good criterion and
yet if you actually talk to the
scientists when they were just looking
at models similarity in responses
clearly intuitively mattered to them but
not when it was pointed out as a bald
scientific principle which is very
interesting in terms of I guess
philosophy of science all right I'm I'm
not going to go in this into this in
detail this is a result these are
different regions that Filippo had
earlier divided the world into this is
the natural variability these are
essentially here's the REA method and
here's just the straight average and
you'll find that in some areas yeah
there's maybe you know a degree
difference and the REA result is usually
higher and then in other areas they're
really you know pretty much identical so
I think in this paper you know what we
say that yeah there r EI changes differ
from simple averaging from few tenths to
1k for temperature a few tenths to ten
percent of precipitation and an
important thing we pointed to the
uncertainty range is narrower in the
Rema any method does that mean that we
succeeded in reducing the uncertainty
kind of if you buy what we did with the
method and important thing the lesson
here in terms of the model reliability
the performance versus the convergence
was that to improve further you had to
really reduce model biases if you buy
into this method so that was actually
the first attempt i think at waiting
models now here's an example from the
work of claudia Tebaldi I took new tea a
summary article that they did about
different means of producing primarily
Beijing
probabilistic models and these are again
for different regions this is for the a
1 b s res scenario and i'll just point
out a couple of them there are three
different methods the tebaldi a tall
green at all and few at all and these
are the raw GCMs again put the seam at
three set and you'll see in some
situations why there's quite a
difference in these three in other
situations like Western North America
and summer there there are some
differences but they're pretty
convergent one of the big differences
all three of these methods use some kind
of waiting the big difference is that
green at all the waiting was done on how
well the model reproduced trends which
is much more difficult for the models to
do than to reproduce you know mean
climate for these particular areas and I
would submit that for the end sep for
the cmap three models that getting
friends right is too tough a test for
them I don't quite have time to go into
why but I think that's one of the
reasons why fear and validly are
reasonably close and green at all tend
to be shifted not always in the same
direction it depends upon the area so
the point is I'm making a point that
yeah waiting depending on what you're
waiting with can make a big difference
in terms of probabilistic methods
estimates of regional climate change so
there's been a lot of searching for the
correct performance metrics for climate
models and as it estimates esta attempts
to rank them and so much it depends upon
the variable considered and it points to
the difficulty of using one grand
performance index for example the Hadley
modeling Center came up with this
overarching index that included a lot of
sub-indices in it and tried to make that
the metric which quite frankly did not
work very well
and my point is the importance of
valuating evaluating broad spectrum of
climate processes and phenomena and a
very nice paper by Peter gloeckler and
colleagues and jg are back in two
thousand eight we're really pretty much
in the same situation now it remains
largely unknown what aspects of observed
climate must be simulated well to make
reliable predictions about future
climate now I'm going to provide you
some examples where people came up with
sometimes simple metrics sometimes other
one by John Walsh and colleagues again
back in two thousand eight and he just i
was looking at model performance over
alaska and greenland again this is with
the cement three models and he just came
up with the retweets square errors of
seasonal cycles of temperature precip
and sea-level pressure and they did find
a relationship one of the things is to
see is there a relationship between the
model errors and the future climate so
there is a tendency they found with of
models with small errors to simulate
larger greenhouse gas warming over the
arctic and greater increases in precip
and that selecting models you know based
on this metric may narrow uncertainty
and team more robust estimates of future
climate change in the Arctic so john
walsh determined that from his point of
view compared to just averaging all
these models that the change for alaska
and greenland should actually be just
change an annual temperature should
actually be larger based on the
application of these metrics another
study by the job i knew that was going
to happen by Francina dominguez and
colleagues at arizona you can imagine
they're very interested in scenarios for
the southwest they work with various
stakeholders and
they looked at the evaluation of the
SEMA three models for winter temperature
and precip and they use in a modified
version of Gog and mearns and also the
reproduction of the 250 Margie potential
hike field to reflect the location of
the subtropical jet stream and to cut to
the conclusion they found that two
models to the ekend the Hat cm3 scored
best for consideration of these three
variables and why we're doing this
because they were developing scenarios
of climate change and they were also
going to be nesting the wharf model in
these GCMs so here's just a little bit
more of a detail about this this is the
area they were looking at this I know
you can't possibly read that scale but I
think you can just see this is the
observations and this is these are the
model precipitation the annual cycle and
of course everybody does a lot better on
temperature these are the models that
you also can't possibly read but that's
okay so most of the models really don't
do so great on the seasonal cycle of
precipitation in the southwest so then
they they combine sort of their modified
Rea these are the different models and
then the circulation score is based on
the 250 ml of our height and they
concluded that indeed when they combine
the scores that those two models that I
indicated above were the best models to
use and so that's what they did now is
that right is that wrong that's not
clear what they have done however is
they come up with a method they come up
with criterion as they judged the models
by those criteria so from the point of
view of producing a publishable piece of
work they've done that in kind of a
lawyerly way and I'm not disagreeing
with them i think these you know i'm not
sure about the rea scores in some ways
but sure I'll give them the circulation
scores and they also went on and found
that they did better in the reproduction
of Enzo but none of the models at that
point we're doing terribly well okay now
we're going to zip forward to evaluation
of Arctic sea ice in the current IPCC so
these are results from the IPCC working
for one chapter nine that is the
evaluation chapter and this shows so
these are all the newer cement five
models and this is the ice Arctic sea
ice extent the heavy red line indicates
the mean for the seam of five models and
the blue represents the mean for the
cement 3 and then these are the
observations from a satellite based
platform so over here it's kind of the
same thing it's just simplifying things
so you can see them more clearly and
this is like you consider you know
interval of the the 95 25 percentiles
for all the models and what you'll see
very distinctly at the time when the
observations were a little less certain
neither of them do well the seam of five
really overestimates the sea ice
tremendously Sima three sorry the seam
at five does much better and the SEMA
thrive from the point when the
observations become more reliable tracks
them pretty well especially that down
turning and you don't see that down
turning in the seam applied models so
this and this is really great progress
because if you look at the last report
they're really the models did well as
you can see much more poorly and so
there was this sense i'll write the sea
ice decreases but at what rate because
at what rate is very important it's
nothing else because of shipping and we
have countries now sort of fighting over
who owns different parts of the Arctic
Ocean which is an interesting of all the
actions people have to take the fact
that they're willing to fight over the
Arctic
is a little disappointing compared to
actually trying to do something about
climate change but that's a a side
comment that I will of course have
removed from the video so what does it
say about some very important large
messages from the IPCC resource that the
nearly ice-free Arctic Ocean before mid
century is likely and those words mean
very specific things in the IPCC lexicon
under RCP 8.5 and you can think of our
CP 8.5 as being sort of business as
usual in other words that's kind of the
direction we're heading however they did
something which i think is pretty
unprecedented for the IPCC for those of
you who have not been involved in many
of these reports you may not be struck
by this but I was struck by this they
actually came up with a subset of subset
of those models that I showed you in the
early slide that most closely reproduce
several factors of climatological mean
state and trend and they came up with
only five models did they consider to be
sufficiently robust in terms of
reproducing these factors and here's an
example where the model selection is
used which is really unusual for the
IPCC and interestingly enough I didn't
realize this but for example the ncar
model is not one of them
this is all cycle oh yes yes definitely
yeah the trends of seasonal out there's
actually more to it that you can look at
I think this is also from chapter 9 and
chapter 14 I think and so here's an
example where the model solution is used
but it's based on a series of
Diagnostics that they think really
relates to processes related to the
biases and in this case the biases in
the current climate really affect the
future changes and when you have that
situation then you really need to pay
more attention to those biases is that
it alright so here are the five I won't
name them this is actually chapter 12
from working group 2 and so here the
five this is the background of I'm
pretty sure these are the cement five
these are probably the seam of three
models and here is where you get these
models that are seen as performing
better producing getting down to what's
considered negligible sea ice extent
many of them before 2050 most of them
and so this ended up being a big message
in the IPCC the possibility of really
having ice-free Arctic before 2050 so I
would say this is an example where
waiting and selecting you can still
argue well isn't there another model
that was pretty good you know what are
the cut-offs but I think this is a good
example where selecting related to
waiting has been pretty functional and I
kudos to the IPCC to a not feeling that
they always have to include all the
models which quite frankly I suspect
it's also partially for political
reasons because the ipcc's the an
international organization and made up
of nation states and they all have
investments in their own climate models
including of course the end karma
okay so here's another example that's
really getting into profit processes and
this is now this was from hall and chew
in 2006 this has been a very
well-traveled result showing that the
snow albedo feedback in some ways a
relatively simple phenomenon is very
that the seasonal cycle of that albedo
feedback is very strongly correlated
with the climate change and from their
analyses of this they think really the
same processes are obtained both in the
seasonal cyclone by the seasonal cycle
what they mean is they just take the
difference in the albedo April versus
March and the difference in the
temperature change April versus March I
mean not temperature change just
seasonal cycle and that becomes this
wrote ratio of percentage change per
Kelvin and then on the other axis is the
same axis nicely of the climate change
and so they really related this that the
snobby feedback strength and the
seasonal cycle contexts are highly
correlated with that in the climate
change context and they demonstrate that
that really had a lot to do with the
processes here's just another slide of
the same thing showing from a remotely
sense platform where they think the
actual seasonal cycle relationship is
and this is for the northern hemisphere
and notice these are at SEMA three
models not many of them really fall in
there they get the relationship right
but not many of them are really within
that sweet spot of the observations
however we move forward to see map five
sorry this is a little blurry and now
you'll see number one same relationship
the colored squares are the seam of five
models and you see that more of them
fall within the observations and this is
again considered progress and I think it
is and i think this
having this kind of relationship it's
really very useful in being able to
diagnose what models you may trust
particularly from the climate change
point of view okay now so I show you
some nice process-oriented studies where
selection mattered but that's always not
the case so for example Pierce at all
looked at future average temperature or
the western US 14 randomly selected GCMs
again from the SEMA three produce
results indistinguishable from those
produced by subset of best models okay
and if you get no relationship well then
in what sense are you are the selecting
the best models giving you better
information rato community and
colleagues looked at a metric
precipitation trend again 11 lee random
selected GCM and produce the same
results as those from 11 best GCM and so
clearly it very much depends upon what
the context both the variable the
process and the region as to whether or
not selection get you anywhere okay now
I'm going to turn to regional models and
this is strongly you know it's the same
idea really selecting waiting them still
models that are developing that are
reproducing processes of the climate
system but this is particularly ready
related to the issue of added value
everyone talks about what's the added
value of your regional model simulation
why is it worth putting in all this
human time and the gazillions of all the
computer resources to generate all this
extra detail if you don't know if that
information is really adding to one's
understanding of climate change so the
IPCC this is very interesting to the
IPCC definition and I think they kind of
love let's say I don't think it's a very
interesting definition something can be
true without being interesting but in
this case I don't think it's really a
useful definition
that added value in down skin Lisa
measure the extent to which the
downscaled climate is closer to
observations then the model from rich
the boundary conditions were obtained
okay fine then quoting myself in a
chapter about downscaling over North
America I really prefer to think of it
as that you're really producing
additional knowledge about the climate
the current and future gained from
applying RCM and from my point of view
yes you expect you hope it's a over
complex topography that my good is that
the regional model doesn't validate
better that's pretty pathetic but I
think that's not sufficient I think it's
necessary but not sufficient and really
much more work has to be done on a
process level these one thing all these
models have error then they're going to
have errors forever so understanding
what the errors do in a process level is
very important okay so now i'm going to
give you an example this ensembles is a
project over europe that was not a few
years ago in which they ran a bunch of
different rcms driven by a bunch of
different GCMs at 25 kilometers and they
came up with different metrics and this
was based on the era 40 that's a
reanalysis product that we're driving
these models and they had a large scale
circulation weather regimes based I
believe on the 250 ml of our Heights
actually different series of eofs of
those I believe a mesoscale signal and
the the names next to these were the
institutions that produce those for this
whole European project three PDS of
daily precip and temperature temperature
and Pacific streams are more and more
important temperature trends and
temperature and precip annual cycle so
they calculate all these there's a
special issue of climate research
dedicated to this 2010
but ultimately and some of them on an
individual basis were somewhat useful
but what they did was they particularly
thought okay they believed it was
important to hit on all of these so they
basically took the product of all six of
those so that he fell down on one you
would essentially have a low score
that's an interesting assumption is that
do we all believe that you have to get
all of them at a high value to be
valuable and here is the result 15
different rcms driven by era 40 and
these are different means of combining
the different metrics so the product is
the the purple one and it's kind of
amazing that that is the weight going up
to there's they're all set up so that
they have to add up to one I mean for
each model not yeah I think that's it so
I'm not quite sure why they do have to
add up to one I can't really tell you
then exactly this should be related
certainly to the the waiting score the
point is model seven the tall poppy did
better than everybody by a lot and so
what's interesting if you read this
article by N's christiansen it's
interesting how they discuss the result
because they kind of downplay the fact
that according to their criteria this
model is far and away the best model so
then the question is well should you
just use that one no because there's
still a belief that these other models
contribute just not as much as this and
I'll we're not going to go through all
this but that model is the KN mi Iraq
motu and the
blue numbers are the highest values for
these different metrics and you can see
that it does best not only overall but
for a number of the individual metrics
and certainly never at the bottom and so
this was very interesting that they
actually you know published this because
there's tremendous sensitivity in the
climate modeling community about bashing
other people's models and you know i
mean it's it's an interesting again i
think sort of a sociology of science
issue well if your model is bad
shouldn't you just admit it and move on
but it's very interesting if you look at
christian instance it at all model they
never say that you should just use that
model fine they can say that the other
models contribute something but it's
really downplayed in this slightly weird
way so you might want to check that out
oh I also want to point out this Ramos
model because it's going to come up in
something else which does let's see
let's see it doesn't do too badly on f1
is the large-scale circulation can't
remember what f3 but it does the poorest
on the third metric and so anyway so
they took all of this crank them all
together decay and simo particularly
looked at produce PDFs of climate and
climate change for European capitals
and so here's the temperature PDF for
climate change for Lisbon so I assume
they did this by taking grid boxes in
the vicinity of Lisbon and remember the
grid size is about 25 kilometers and
essentially that the solid one is the
current climate the future is the
climate I believe in the mid 21st
century and you do see shifts and
there's something wrong with this I
don't know how I screwed this up the
point is that these lines behind it the
heavier lines are weighted according to
those finally aggregate scores and the
lines behind them are you can think of
it as being unweighted and really the
bottom line of decay and simo was that
you know the weighting didn't matter in
the PDF which was really interesting
because you'll find that there are now a
lot of articles like this and the point
is well what happens when you combine
you know so many different metrics
especially going to restrict the values
they can have and we're working on a
couple of cases that pretty much
demonstrate that with this kind of
system it's almost impossible to get a
strong effect what happened I'm moving
through my own slides hmm hello
okay so now I'm going to provide some
examples from this program that I
directed it still exists but the
simulations have finished it's in the
North American regional climate change
assessment program and we were looking
at multiple uncertainties and regional
global climate models using four
different global climate models to see
map three variety and sixty regional
model and the year now is that a 50
kilometer resolution about 30 miles and
we produce this also for producing
climate scenarios for the impacts and
adaptation assessments and also to
establish the credibility and there are
many participants many funding agencies
and there's the domain at 50 kilometers
showing the topography so I'm going to
be discussing several different things
from this starting off with you always
with a regional climate model project
you always do simulations using some
kind of reanalysis and reanalysis is a
product that combines both the
forecasting model and then assimilates
observations so it's considered to be
the best boundary conditions you're
going to get okay and so we had 25 years
of that and one of the set of results
I'll show you is just related to that
then we did climate change simulations
with the a to s res scenario for GCMs
against six our CMS and then we also did
some time slice experiments with just
atmospheric models and I'll skip the
rest of that okay so Melissa bukovski a
project scientist working my group we
thought okay well you know these very
smart european guys also in the
mid-latitudes they thought these six
metrix would be useful might be worth
doing this for a different domains so we
kind of reproduced those and we found
something very interesting that so here
are the six different GCMs this is that
Canadian GCM again that was labeled
ouranos on the other slide and here's
the UK Met Office regional model Wharf
that many of you have worked with and
these show the metrics with and without
the large-scale forcing parameter that
first metric and the CRC em when you
include that metric becomes by far the
most dominant model in terms of
producing well and it doesn't have that
much of an effect they actually make
some of them certainly worse it's a
matter of fact a lot of them practically
all of them I didn't really notice that
before so the point is so what does that
mean I mean that large scale parameter
or metric number when there are many
more types done by taking the EOS of the
250ml of our height and there are like
12 different as you will weather types
whereas the Europeans only found four
and so one of the issues is well that's
very interesting maybe it has to do with
the greater variability of the climate
over North America and melissa is
working on this now and we don't
completely have a an answer for this but
this is a gang kind of interesting so
we've got this one tall poppy when we
use all of them what does that mean in
terms of the contribution of the other
models and we don't actually know that
yet
now one of the things that I found very
interesting my time is racing along here
is a statement made in the IPCC working
group won the chapter on evaluations is
that there's now high confidence
downscaling adds value both in regions
with highly variable topography and
various small scale phenomena now isn't
that what it's supposed to be doing yes
the point is that it resolves smaller
scale phenomenon ergo it should be able
to reproduce those so in on one level
it's trivial but again according to our
definition of added value that's really
not sufficient because it's really quite
frankly it just seems in most contexts
to be expected that it's going to do
better than a course arranged coarser
model when looking at high scale
phenomenon but it's interesting that the
IPCC actually said this however it's
also interesting that even though we've
had all these different comparison
projects like three different ones over
Europe none of those results contributed
to any of the major messages about
climate change and what does that mean
if they're saying on one side that
downscale does add value but we're
really not going to include anything
from these in our estimates and so I
think there's a bit of a disconnect
there so another thing I think is that I
don't think the community Regional
modelling community and now analysts
have done a very good job of really
establishing what added value is so if
any of you are out there playing around
with regional models this could be a
very useful thing to get involved in
because I think it's a lot more
complicated than just reducing biases
and it has to do with what happens to
processes when there are errors all
right to wait or not to wait there was a
very nice meeting at NCAR an IPCC expert
meeting on evaluating mmes and this is
what we concluded you could use ranking
to select subsets of models but for one
thing you have to make sure and this is
a little some things that we're not done
in the AR for report to make sure that
these differences among the models are
really statistically significant
otherwise you know what is the point but
ultimately the selection of the metric
is crucial you're never going to find
the golden metric that can represent
everything and is it really a truly
meaningful one from a process point of
view and I'm actually surprised that the
community has tried to use I think
relatively superficial metric about
these things without really getting into
more process level work ok so where are
we now in terms of waiting even though
regional models add value there's no
Universal strategy for waiting the
projections from different models based
on their historical performance yes
except for example if you have a sea ice
example where there is model selection
which the IPCC really trotted out so I
think the problem is that there's summat
different regions in the world there are
so many processes that it would be very
difficult to come up with just a few
metrics that would work everywhere and I
think there's a lot of work to be done
in that more process-oriented approaches
all right so I've already really told
you about how and to also the changes in
the arctic sea is now i'm going to give
you in my rapidly disappearing time what
we've been trying to do in our cap and
again this is work some of which has
been spearheaded by melissa bukovski and
so this is what we call establishing
process level differential credibility
of regional scale climate simulations we
should probably turn that into an
acronym and then it will really sell in
ohio so this is determining through
in-depth process level analysis of
climate simulations of current or past
climate the ability the model to
reproduce those aspects of climate
system is responsible for the particular
regional climate and then analyzing the
model response if you
forcing and determining specifically how
model errors in the current simulation
affect the models response to the future
forcing and which model errors really
matter and I think we don't know that so
we're really looking for a process-based
integrated expert judgment approach to
what degree the models response to the
future forcing is deemed credible and my
example as I promised dr. booth in an
earlier conversation is about process
level analysis of the North American
monsoon and so here are our six regional
models and these are results for
precipitation for let's say the monsoon
season june july august September
average precipitation rate and these are
the ones driven by re analyses so in a
sense the best boundary conditions
you're going to get here are
observations from the University of
Delaware data set and you'll see there
are commonalities and differences the
models tend to over produce
precipitation in relation to the
topography the lower part of mexico to
to you in you can't see this very
clearly but here's Arizona here's New
Mexico there's Baja but they also tend
to many of them not all intend to under
predict precipitation in New Mexico and
Arizona so one thing you could do is
just you know you take the root mean
square errors of those precip biases and
you come up with something and you can
rank them but it's that really that
useful no because it's really more
useful to find out least to us what's
happening so here is the near surface
moisture flux for the six different
models against the North American
regional reanalysis and its really
interesting some of the models so what
you want to see for example is this this
moisture flux going up the Gulf of
California
into Arizona this is the NAR actually
exaggerate this a bit it also its
moisture its moisture is probably a
little higher than in reality the models
get it yeah yeah this is in grams per
kilogram meters per second so its
moisture flux then where the arrows are
though there's there are some places and
colors right what you have is the colors
or representing the direction okay is
the direction of the arrows all right
the colors indicate the amount of
moisture and the the combination of the
amount of moisture and the temperature I
think they do but I can't remember
exactly what that length is good
question so a couple of interesting
things what a thing is that the Hadley
model does actually a pretty good job at
least getting the direction of the flow
it's a little under prediction but as i
said i think the nar over predicted the
amounts of moisture some of them do
pretty poorly they don't really go up
the Gulf really at all and then some of
them are kind of the CR cm is still
trying to figure out what's going on
with those squigglies actually and this
has been published in the journal of
climate so the point was say well really
how they do with moisture flux is
probably much more important than how
they do with just reproducing mean
precipitation and you can read more
details of this in the journal of
climate article
now this is a plot also of the ends up
driven simulations of the scatter plot
of five day averaged precipitation for
the seasonal cycle and you can see that
most of the models use this pink one mm5
kind of weak but most of them get the
basic seasonal cycle of the south of the
North American monsoon although some of
them are clearly more ragged than others
but that's n sep and it's interesting
that for example in ensembles the models
were weighted based on their performance
with these perfect boundary conditions
and as you'll see that can be very
different from what happens to these
models when they're driven by gc-ms and
I think that's the next slide it is hmmm
so again these are the observations of
precipitation and this is over i believe
just Arizona and New Mexico that area a
number of the rcms depending upon which
model they're driven by have now no
monsoon at all a couple of them have
this gigantic monsoon that is completely
misplaced seasonally and that's an
incredibly huge difference if you go
back to what happens with the N set
driving conditions so why on earth you
would want to wait models when they're
driven by gc-ms by how they do with
perfect conditions I can't really
imagine but that's what's been done come
on
okay good I'm virtually done so here is
just sort of like a simplified graph of
the precipitation plots the seasonal
cycle and the model so here are the
models that have been driven by the gfdl
and note the hat rm3 model that UK Met
Office model it's both driven by the
gfdl and by the Hat cm3 so we had the
same model two different GCMs so driven
by the gfdl it kind of goes bananas the
it has I guess you can say it has a
monsoon but it's shifted quite
dramatically in terms of its cycle and
the only model that does well is this
time slice which is the cam the gfdl
rather time slice using observe sea
surface temperatures for the global
model and it's exaggerated but at least
it gets that seasonal cycle correct so
clearly the gfdl model is doing
something very bad to these models
interestingly enough we go down so here
we have the Hat rm3 again and golly gee
it again you know different variability
but it gets the monsoon circulation as
does even the poor mm5 even though it's
somewhat exaggerated now what's really
interesting the Hat rm3 models it had a
terrible terrible bias in temperature in
the Great Plains I mean sort of
unbelievable such that when we submitted
this bands article one reviewer came
back and said you should throw that
model out that model is garbage it had a
bias and the great plains of in the
summer of like five degrees C incredible
and yet we're in a situation where that
model does better with the North
American monsoon than any other model so
what well you say does it not matter for
the North American months in that it has
this horrible bias in the Great Plains
number one the bias actually gets
smaller when it's turned by the GCM
which is also an interesting point so
melissa is still coming up with deeper
process level explanations for this but
it's it's really interesting at least in
this case to see just how dominant the
driving GCM is in terms of reproducing
the stuff I think I'm a chilly finished
what do we need to make further progress
oh yes many more in-depth process
oriented studies that examine the
plausibility of process change under
future forcing what error is really
matter and which don't and I also like
to kind of harp on what is the danger of
false certainty especially for you're
using results of climate models for
adaptation planning what's the danger of
only looking at a much smaller amount of
the uncertainty because you've
eliminated models and these are the
kinds of questions that can keep on up
at night but I suspect that the problem
of false certainty could actually be
much more deadly than the problem of too
much uncertainty and finally yes I'm
from New York not far from here this is
from The New Yorker big book of global
warming cartoons showing sea-level rise
in New York so I enjoy showing this I
have the original poster and I got this
one and then I realized I kept showing
us some thinking huh then I realize how
this is the Empire State Building and I
realize this is you know deep science
the kind of stuff I really like to do
that I could actually calculate what
would be the sea level rise such that
there would only be nine floors left of
the Empire State Building all right so
audience
how high would the sea level rise have
to be any guesses
roughly the man wins a kewpie doll 320
meters folks which I believe even if all
of the land ice glaciers and everything
Antarctica everything melted I don't
think we could come up with 320 meters
so I'm thinking of writing to the New
Yorker and saying you know they're
misleading people last of it is better
because i'm averaging the Chrysler
Building that's all right there you go
well I'm happy to go her trip with you
to each of those and stand out that you
know before the that floor and just look
out over the vision of the flooded city
all right that's it thanks i'm happy to
take any questions and sorry its run
over but it hasn't really